about the eurozone summit we had the
occasion to discuss the strategic
approach and how is it possible in the
short term in the mid term to try to
make progress on this important topic
point one the ESM as you know if witched
an agreement a political agreement in
the past based on this important project
on this important role and its necessity
it's a necessity for the Euro group to
continue to work on the technical level
in order to be able to implement this
first important point breaks its
elections in the UK I have had the
occasion this morning to congratulate
Prime Minister Boris Johnson it is a
clear victory and we expect that the
British Parliament will vote as soon as
possible disagreement this withdrawal
agreement it's very important in our
opinion because we are ready we are
ready to start the next phase we are
ready also to defend and to promote the
European interest the level playing
field is a very important role for us we
will try also to continue the good way
of working we have experimented the
recent years congratulations from my
part to Boris Johnson to the his victory
now indeed we expect the ratification of
the withdrawal agreement to be ended by
January we are ready to move to the next
phase in our relationship we want our
future relationship to be as close as
possible in full respect of
principles the European Council today
has tasked us the European Commission
again to remain the union's negotiator
for the next phase of the talks the
timeframe ahead of us is very
challenging we will get to have to work
as soon as possible we will be ready to
get the most out of the short period
available but for me it is important at
this moment to say that the United
Kingdom yes will become a third country
but at the very end we will have an
unprecedented partnership this is not
the end of something this is the
beginning of excellent future relations
between good neighbors of course a
stronger Europe needs a strong euro
without any questions we are one of the
three largest global economies we are
the largest global market and we are the
first foreign investor even in places
that are incredibly far from us and yet
we're still punching below weight so it
was a very interesting and vivid debate
today that the International role of the
euro has to rise as to gain more
importance for that we have to go
forward in our homework because we're
not done with the structure we have to
complete the capital market union this
means access for example for SMEs all
over Europe we have to move forward in
the banking union there of course it's
always a question of sequences that is
debated but the common goal is clear and
there is a common understanding about
that
we have agreed that the European Union
will be climate-neutral by 2050 the
adoption of this target sends a clear
signal there are citizens who demand
more ambitious climate action in order
to fulfill the commitments of the Paris
agreement we do this decision at the
fourth anniversary of this historical
climate agreement this is an important
decision not only for us present here
today but also for the future and future
generations one member state is not yet
ready to commit to the implementation of
the 2050 target but I'm sure we will be
able to find a way forward